it is slowly happening Donald Trump is
successfully pushing out everybody but
Robert Muller who has some say or
oversight over the Trump Russia
investigation you'll remember that
Donald Trump fired FBI director James
Comey in order to interfere with
investigating his connections to Russia
that led to the appointment of special
counsel of a special prosecutor Robert
Muller Attorney General Jeff Sessions
recused himself because of his personal
conflicts of interest in having lied
about Russian contact and Donald Trump
eventually forced him out and put in
Matthew Whitaker someone actively
hostile to the Trump Russia probe then
Trump said he was going to replace
Matthew Whitaker with the permanent
selection of William Barr also someone
hostile to the Trump Russia probe but we
had rod Rosenstein the Deputy Attorney
General he was still there overseeing
the investigation for quite some time
breaking news this morning
rod Rosenstein is resigning according to
CBS News Rosenstein will leave when
William Barr the new Attorney General is
confirmed if indeed he gets confirmed
and there's every indication that he
will so let's cut through all the
sidebar issues here the issue is what
does this mean for the Trump Russia
probe which just had its grand jury
extended up to six months as I told you
on Monday I completely understand why
Rosenstein would want out he's been
treated horribly by Trump he's been put
in an impossible position why not leave
but he has sort of been the last line of
defense here for Robert Muller the one
positive here is that now with a
Democratic House if indeed Donald
Trump's henchmen find a way to shut down
the Trump Russia probe once rod
Rosenstein leaves and maybe not fire
Robert Muller but prevents him from
being able to really carry out his
investigative work
Democrats will call Muller into open
committee hearings in the house Intel
committee and a lot will come out which
I cannot imagine as to Donald Trump's
advantage now the counter to all of this
concern is that Rosen Stein did
previously say to people that he would
not leave his position unless he was
satisfied and
confident that leaving wouldn't endanger
the molar probe so a more sort of
charitable perspective on this would be
that Rosenstein is now comfortable
leaving because he's aware that either
the molar probe is almost over or that
if he leaves now it would be very
difficult to suppress what it is that
ultimately is going to come out because
the investigation is so advanced in
terms of its process so you know if
we're looking at the upside I will also
remind you that the molar probe is just
one angle in the criminal Trump
investigations you've got the Southern
District of New York you have multiple
attorneys general it's a very long list
and even successful obstruction of
robert muller if that's what ultimately
is going to happen here as a result of
Rosenstein being the last sort of a
pillar of defensive molar to fall allows
that to happen it's not actually clear
that at this point it would stop Trump's
legal trouble the genie does appear to
be out of the where do genies come from
Pat I don't even remodel the bottle yeah
the bottle yes so I think that this is
good news there at least there's no
evidence to suggest that it's bad news
yet because it's not like rod Rosenstein
was forced out I have to hope that he
knows what's going on and that Muller is
wrapping up the investigation soon so
nothing is put at risk he was one of
those few buffers that we had remaining
in the Justice Department and I just
don't see him resigning without the
assurance that everything is gonna be
protected that the Trump Russian
investigation would continue on and that
everything would be able to continue you
know I just don't see it it's concerning
but I tend to agree that Rosenstein is
not stupid molars not stupid
I assume that there is a gameplan here
and Rosenstein might be leaving because
Muller is getting close to wrapping this
up but he also might be leaving because
Muller is not done but we've sort of
surpassed the point of no return in this
investigation where what Muller has is
so damaging and incontrovertible that
any attempt to shut it down at this
point could gloriously backfire we'll
have to wait and see but I want to hear
from you what do you think the
consequences are of Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein resigning let me
know on Twitter at D Pakman make sure
you're following the show on Twitter -
at David Pakman show
one of today's sponsors is privacy
dot-com / Pakman this is a free service
that I've actually been using myself for
a while now and I love it
you just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
coms mobile app or browser extension for
Firefox and Chrome and what that does is
allow you to instantly create virtual
credit cards that are linked to your
bank account so that you're not actually
putting your real debit card number on
the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5.00 towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below